Trascrizione: Christina Craver
Revisore: Martina Margoni
Buongiorno.
Mi chiedono: "Cosa fai?"
"Sono biologa, ricercatrice."
"Ah bello e ... cosa ricerchi?"
"Studio gli animali in natura."
"Ah e ...perché?"
O addirittura, "Ah e... a cosa serve?"
Già, perché...
Ho immaginato che mi venisse chiesto anche oggi.
Così, prima di rispondere, ho percorso
un viaggio di riscoperta, partendo da me stessa.
Mi sono ritrovata a indulgere
sugli appunti di campo da bambina
descrivevo un regolo come in una favola.
Mescevo qualificazione di forma e colore per cui cercavo di essere rigorosa con giudizi estetici:
uno stupendo uccellino.
Stupendo. Lo stupore.
Lo stupore e la conoscenza hanno
radici comuni nel pensiero occidentale
e anche nello sviluppo intellettivo:
non esiste apprendimento senza curiosità.
e la ricompensa, la molla,
è proprio quella straordinaria soddisfazione di vedere la meraviglia che si dischiude in conoscenza.
Forse lo stesso stupore, la stessa meraviglia che troviamo nei primi trattati sulla natura
come questo di Lucrezio,
in cui la forma è quella poetica
proprio per dare forza alle parole
cosi che si tramutassero in immagini.
Il metodo scientifico, nella sua formulazione classica
prevede una fase di osservazione
dei fenomeni e di generalizzazione in ipotesi
e una fase di formalizzazione in leggi
e di verifica sperimentale.
Non esiste però verifica o non esiste osservazione
senza misurazione di quelle grandezze che fanno parte delle ipotesi.
Così gli scienziati hanno sempre avuto bisogno di guardare oltre
di trovare, di andare oltre i propri sensi
e così si sono affidati a strumenti, alla tecnologia,
la capacità di modificare il reale
per poter provare o falsificare le proprie ipotesi.
E' come se gli scienziati interessati nel mondo naturale cercassero mille occhi
mille sensi, per riuscire a soddisfare
la curiosità che hanno del mondo naturale.
E così non esiste teoria copernicana
senza il telescopio di Galileo.
O teoria cellulare senza il microscopio di Leeuwenhoek.
O teoria del bosone di Higgs senza acceleratore nucleare.
O meglio, le teorie possono essere formalizzate
ma non possono trovare verifica o
falsificazione senza la misurazione.
Noi studiosi degli animali in natura,
ecologici della fauna
stiamo convergendo negli ultimi anni su teorie unificatrici, paradigmi, campi di ricerca
e questo indica l'inizio della maturità
della nostra giovane disciplina.
E' giunto dunque anche per noi
il momento di andare oltre
di andare oltre i nostri sensi e ricercare strumenti che ci permettono di misurare
quelle grandezze che sono alla base delle
nostre ipotesi e delle nostre teorie.
In biologia sono stati inventati microscopi ottici, elettronici, spettrometri di massa, sequenziatori,
che ci hanno consentito
di indagare l'infinitamente piccolo
ma stranamente in ecologia
ci siamo fidati, forse troppo a lungo
dei nostri poveri occhi.
Forse perché i fenomeni vengono osservati grossomodo
alla nostra stessa scala spazio temporale.
Però è incredibile, paradossale, perché
è stata prima scoperta la struttura del Dna
ricorrono quest' anno sessanta anni, che i meccanismi di migrazione delle rondini
che pure sono sotto gli occhi di tutti e vantano la descrizione addirittura dei greci e dei latini.
Ora però stiamo recuperando, per esempio abbiamo messo delle telecamere
quasi nascoste, per visualizzare
il comportamento dei tassi
come in questo studio
che è stato precursore di tecniche più raffinate
come ad esempio le termocamere a infrarossi per la visione notturna
con cui possiamo indagare strani comportamenti: ad esempio la curiosità della volpe per un capriolo
oppure l'esitazione e i vari tentativi, le varie tecniche di un gruppo di cervi nel passare una staccionata
o ancora il combattimento tra due daini adulti.
o ancora le fotocamere digitali automatiche, che noi chiamiamo trappole fotografiche
grazie a cui abbiamo rilevato
la presenza di specie a rischio d'estinzione
o addirittura ne abbiamo descritto delle nuove.
non "blogger". Un blogger usa la tecnologia, Internet, per far sapere al mondo quello che pensa.
Un "bio-logger", invece, prende un pezzo di tecnologia lo mette ad un animale
e lascia che sia l' animale
a raccontarci della sua esistenza.
Così il punto di vista
è quello della specie che è oggetto di studio
che è oggetto dell'osservazione
Forse la sfida più incredibile degli ultimi anni è stata quella di studiare il movimento degli animali
l'ecologia del movimento, ossia gli spostamenti
degli animali nell' ambiente.
E questo perché il movimento racchiude in sè la forza, la caratteristica spazio-temporale dell'ecologia.
E' come se fosse l'evoluzione qui e ora.
E così con gli occhi delle specie che studiamo osserviamo il mondo.
Come in questo caso la migrazione delle renne vista dagli occhi di una renna che sta migrando
e che indossa un collare con una fotocamera.
E cosi facendo, con gli occhi
delle specie che studiamo
abbiamo cominciato a "cambiare le evidenze"
a descrivere i fenomeni come sono
e non pensavamo che fossero.
E allora gli studiosi degli animali hanno rivelato che, un piccolo animale come la sterna artica
pesa soltanto un etto, vola settanta
mila chilometri in una stagione
pur di assicurarsi la nutrizione nei mari più pescosi al mondo che sono quelli ai due estremi poli
nel Mare Artico e nel Mare Antartico
e pensate che la via del ritorno
non la fa in linea retta
ma fa una deviazione di quasi ventimila chilometri
pur di non doversi trovare a volare controvento,
così risparmiando l'energia.
Nella sua vita percorre tre volte andata
e ritorno la distanza Terra-Luna.
Oppure ancora abbiamo individuato
e finalmente iniziato a proteggere i siti
di nidificazione delle tartarughe marine
un animale fondamentale nella catena trofica marina
che è così importante anche
per la sopravvivenza dell'uomo
e che pure è a rischio d'estinzione.
O ancora abbiamo studiato che il capriolo, un animale sedentario
--no, forse non lo è,
non è sedentario per nulla.
E compie delle migrazioni risalendo per valli
e per ripidi versanti fino a raggiungere i pascoli d'alta quota pur di nutrirsi dei germogli
più freschi e ricchi, un po' come hanno fatto i pastori con il bestiame per migliaia di anni.
Dunque grazie a questi strumenti
siamo riusciti a misurare le grandezze
e a provare o a falsificare le nostre ipotesi
e le nostre teorie.
E tutte queste ipotesi confluiscono intorno allo stesso medesimo principio...
quel delicato equilibrio dinamico tra energia spesa ed energia guadagnata per assicurarsi
la sopravvivenza e il successo riproduttivo.
Un equilibro dinamico che si è formato e continua a formarsi nel nastro infinito dell'evoluzione.
Un equilibro dinamico di cui noi stessi facciamo parte e da cui noi stessi siamo stati originati
ma che, unica tra le specie, siamo in grado di modificare volontariamente.
E così dopo avere "cambiato le evidenze",
ricerca dopo ricerca
abbiamo cominciato a "evidenziare il cambiamento".
Abbiamo trovato che la medesima specie di cui parlavo, il capriolo,
senza neve in inverno non migra più
se ne stà in pascoli d'alta quota nutrendosi di povere erbe secche
oppure cominciando a disperde energie in inutili viaggi tra monte e valle.
O ancora abbiamo trovato che, sì, alcune renne ancora migrano, però poi trovano un ostacolo
la strada costruita dall'uomo, e là si fermano immobili, in gruppo
per settimane senza sapere come comportarsi,
cosa fare
arrivando addirittura a consumare le proprie energie fino a morire di fame.
Addirittura abbiamo visto che la lepre nordamericana
che l'evoluzione ha fatto sì che cambiasse il proprio mantello in bianco
durante l'inverno per risultare mimetica nella neve, ora mimetica non lo è più
e così nel manto bruno, privo di neve a causa dei cambiamenti che stiamo osservando
se ne sta lì, immobile,
pensando di essere invisibile, ma invisibile non è.
Questo è quello che succede quando modifichiamo, distruggiamo una foresta tropicale di milioni di anni.
Stiamo evidenziando un cambiamento: dalla ricchezza all' impoverimento
dalla diversità e dalla complessità alla monotonia.
Pretenderemmo che le specie contraessero il proprio tempo evolutivo
che è di centinaia di migliaia di milioni di anni, in un battito di ciglia, in cinquanta-settanta anni.
E così, le specie generaliste, si adattano
le specie che generaliste non sono,
più specializzate, si estinguono.
La meravigliosa diversità, scompare.
E' come se avessimo di fronte
un quadro di Van Gogh
con i colori ancora freschi,
ancora vibranti, ancora pulsanti
e decidessimo di dare una manata
così che quell'inesplicato equilibrio viene deturpato
e lo stupore scompare.
Ma di una cosa ci siamo dimenticati
noi non guardiamo il quadro,
noi siamo nel quadro.
E così inevitabilmente arrivano le conseguenze
se noi dimentichiamo di essere parte integrante di quel medesimo equilibrio dinamico
le conseguenze possono essere enormi e deturpanti
fino a compromettere in maniera imprevista e imprevedibile
la qualità della vita, addirittura fino a compromettere la sopravvivenza stessa
e purtroppo queste sono immagini di cronaca.
Noi andiamo ancor di più a negare noi stessi.
Se non ricordiamo di essere parte di questo equilibrio dinamico, noi usiamo la nostra etica
usiamo la pragmatica, quell'unica capacità dell' uomo di modificare il reale consapevolmente
per negare il reale e dunque noi stessi.
Torno da dove sono partita: lo stupore di un bambino, una generazione più in là.
Studi mostrano che l'infanzia occidentale oggigiorno è più carica di violenza
e avrà un'aspettativa di vita minore dalla nostra, perché è intrappolata da mille schermi
incapace di creare un legame con la Natura, di creare, capire, la relazione tra il sè e il là fuori
di relazionarsi con quelle paure, quelle abilità che sono parte di noi stessi, in quanto specie animale.
Non si può cancellare un milione d'anni di evoluzione dietro lo schermo di un tablet.
E così, studi, film, simposi, indicano una possibilità: quella del "re-wild ourselves"
di ricercare una dimensione di noi stessi più ricca e al contempo più semplice.
Attenzione non è un richiamo bucolico ai bei tempi andati, detto in Europa poi
dove la distruzione si perpetra da duemila anni. Semmai è un allarme, una sveglia, un grido
quello del fatto che abbiamo bisogno di spazi selvaggi, dove lasciare fare
dove l'uomo si possa sentire solo un altro uomo, un'altra specie animale.
Per il bene della terra, per la salvezza di noi stessi.
E se tutto questo sembra utopico, assurdo,
guardando queste immagini
forse vediamo che non lo è.
Guardate cosa succede in pochi decenni
lasciando fare
la foresta ritorna, gli animali la ripopolano, la diversità, la meravigliosa diversità, risorge.
Oppure, ricordate le tartarughe marine
esistono luoghi dove le popolazioni locali si sono trasformate da persecutrici a paladine
e hanno costruito scuole per bambini altrimenti analfabeti grazie ai proventi della conservazione.
Io non ho ricette per la qualità della vita.
Nè mi è stato chiesto di fornirne, oggi.
Purtroppo i suggerimenti possono essere dimenticati e le contraddizioni sono molte.
Posso solo tornare a fare il mio mestiere, di cui forse però, ho compreso il perché...
Continuerò a cercare di conoscere.
Continuerò a meravigliarmi.
E di sicuro insegnerò a cercarla.
La meraviglia.
Grazie.